alors nous contestons totalement les
faits et vu que l'affaire est toujours
en cours au niveau judiciaire nous
pouvons pas plus nous exprimer là dessus
mais en tout cas ni moi ni mon conjoint
en Europe ça me responsable de ce qui
s'est passé et la seule chose dont nous
avons pu être coupable c'est de ne pas
avoir vu que notre chaîne n'était pas
bien en fait
moi je peux dire que aussi avant
l'arrivée de betka et là il y a plein de
gens qui peuvent le témoigner
il y avait pas il y avait pas autant de
je voulais sauveuses je parle de cette
checkeuse mais techniquement quand tu
fais 250 Tik Tok tous les jours que tu
invites les gens à créer des groupes
pour des viols pour des agressions que
tu mets des noms de personnes qui n'ont
rien à voir dedans et que tu incite
comme ça la haine c'est pas très
c'est pas très